[Musik]
die taliban erobern afghanistan
unaufhaltsam und überraschend schnell
inzwischen sind sie bis in die
hauptstadt kabul vorgedrungen die usa
evakuieren ihre botschaft unter
hochdruck bereitet die bundeswehr die
flucht deutscher diplomaten und
mitarbeiter vor der afghanische
präsident hat das land wohl bereits
verlassen
die ereignisse in afghanistan
überschlagen sich herzlich willkommen zu
einem zdf spezial
die afghanische regierung hat kampflos
kapituliert die taliban stehen vor der
vollständigen machtübernahme nach was 20
jahren nato und bundeswehr einsatz in
afghanistan von den selbsternannten
gotteskriegern was dem handumdrehen
erobert gleichschalten wir noch nach
kabul und reden mit einem deutschen
helfer vor ort aber erstmal julia held
über den einsatz am hindukusch
nur einen tag nach dem 11 september
erklärt der un sicherheitsrat die usa
hätten das recht zurückzuschlagen schon
am 17 oktober beginnt die von der nato
geführte operation enduring freedom
bombenangriffe auf afghanistan
das land hat da bereits viele jahre
krieg hinter sich bürgerkrieg
stellvertreterkriege zustände die die
taliban erst groß gemacht haben im
november 2001 gelingt es mit hilfe von
bodentruppen die islamisten in weiten
landesteilen zurückzudrängen an der
anschließenden sicherheits und
wiederaufbau mission beteiligen sich
auch die deutschen
2001 wird eine übergangsregierung
eingesetzt unter führung des präsidenten
hamid karsai aber auch wenn der 2004 in
parlamentswahlen bestätigt wird ein
funktionierender staatsapparat entsteht
nicht die regierung gilt als faktisch
machtlos und korrupt dass der westen
parallel verschiedenste warlords
unterstützt schwächt sie zusätzlich
schon bald können die taliban wieder an
stärke zurückgewinnen
auch die ausbildung der afghanischen
truppen auch durch die bundeswehr wird
als wenig erfolgreich zwar wird der
al-kaida- chef osama bin laden im mai
2011 von us-spezialkräften getötet und
auch der internationale kampf einsatz
wird 2014 offiziell beendet friedlich
aber sind die zeiten nicht
us präsident donald frank muss 2017
gegen alle ankündigungen den us
truppenabzug verschieben er schickt
zusätzliche soldaten an den hindukusch
gegen die immer stärker werdenden
pianisten
dann jedoch im frühjahr 2020 nach
verhandlungen mit den taliban
versprechen die usa doch einen
vollständigen abzug ihrer truppen
seither haben die taliban das land im
rekordtempo zurückerobert und während
jetzt auch die letzten westlichen
vertreter aus dem land geflogen werden
liegt die macht in afghanistan seit
heute wohl auch offiziell wieder in der
hand der taliban
ja und zwar konnte la banerjee
beobachtet für uns die politische
reaktionen in der hauptstadt baku dollar
wie groß das denn das entsetzen über den
schnellen vormarsch der taliban die
schnelle kapitulation der afghanischen
regierung die bestürzung ist hier in
berlin schon mit händen zu greifen in
allen gesprächen vor allem darüber dass
man sich gemeinsam mit den westlichen
verbündeten so sehr vertan hat was die
zeitschiene angeht man hatte wohl
gedacht dass man nach all den jahren der
der militärischen ausbildung der
afghanischen armee und auch der
milliarden die man dort in die
aufrüstung gesteckt hat dieser armee mit
mehr gegenwehr rechnen könne dass es
jetzt eben ausgeblieben und damit kommt
auch sehr viel mehr druck in die
rückholaktion rein die die verbündeten
schon gemeinsam vorbereitet hatten jetzt
aber eben sehen dass es eher um stunden
als um tage geht und wir warten jetzt
eigentlich minütlich auf eine erklärung
von aussenminister maß der hier den
ganzen tag zusammen mit der
verteidigungsministerin und anderen
stellen verhandelt hat und bekanntgeben
will wie es jetzt weitergeht mit der
rückholaktion und die opposition
sprechen von einem beispiellosen
versagen bei der rettung afghanische
kräfte ja das ist richtig das ist der
ausdruck gewesen von jürgen trittin der
damit auch persönlich außenminister maß
gemeint hat und ihm vorwirft da viel zu
langsam gewesen zu sein nicht schnell
genug dafür gesorgt zu haben
unbürokratisch auch afghanische
ortskräfte zurückzuholen und er ist auch
nicht der einzige ich habe heute mit der
fdp
verteidigungspolitikerin marie-agnes
strack-zimmermann gesprochen die sagte
die fdp fordere schon seit jahren eine
bessere auswertung des gesamten
einsatzes hätte man das gemacht hätte
man vielleicht doch früher erkennen
können dass die armee sich da so schnell
geschlagen geben würde und sie fordert
jetzt also eine nachträgliche
aufarbeitung auch noch mit blick auf
andere militäreinsätze zum beispiel in
mali
meine frage steht ja natürlich auch im
raum war alles umsonst 20 jahre
bundeswehr einsatz deutscher soldaten
die dort gefallen sind wie ist die
einschätzung in berlin eine positive
bilanz zieht hier in den letzten tagen
sicherlich keiner mehr horst seehofer
hat heute gegenüber der augsburger
allgemeinen zeitung vom montag gesagt
das ganze
sei also ein beweis des scheiterns
gewesen man habe es nicht geschafft die
lebensbedingungen zu verbessern und
stabilität ins land zu bringen auch
annegret kramp karrenbauer hat bereits
vor drei tagen gesagt das ist nicht gut
gelaufen ist sei nicht gelungen
afghanistan nachhaltig positiv zu wenden
die linke spricht sogar von einem
kompletten militärischen versagen und
die afg hat heute schon einmal ein asyl
moratorium gefordert mit blick auf
diejenigen die jetzt aus afghanistan
flüchten und sich vielleicht auch mit
europa richtung europa auf den weg
machen so zieht heute hier jeder seine
eigenen schlüsse aus den ereignissen
vielen dank und tyler beechey
die zeit drängt wer kann flieht oder ist
bereits geflohen über die angst fehler
afghaninnen und afghanen vor den taliban
report
kabul heute vormittag mehr als vier
millionen menschen zwischen angespannter
angst und panischer furcht vor der
zukunft die stadt ist umzingelt
chaotische szenen an bankautomaten
wer kann deckt sich noch ein mit bargeld
mit lebensmitteln niemand weiß was die
gefürchteten islamischen terroristen
vorhaben aber die erinnerung an deren
schreckensherrschaft vor mehr als 20
jahren ist bei vielen vor allem afghanen
noch sehr präsent schon gestern gab es
lange schlangen bei der ausreise nach
pakistan gehe die taliban auch an dieser
grenze die kontrolle übernahmen in den
letzten tagen schon haben zehntausende
aus dem ganzen land in kabul zuflucht
gesucht in der hoffnung hier sicher zu
sein wir konnten fliehen aber wir
mussten mit ansehen wie sie die männer
im dorf ermordet haben weil die
angeblich alle für polizei armee oder
für die regierung gearbeitet hätten die
taliban werden uns frauen schlagen
unsere jungen töten und die schulen
schließen
unterdessen versucht die afghanische
regierung die bevölkerung zu beruhigen
man werde mit den taliban eine geordnete
machtübergabe aushandeln
ich versichere allen bürgern kabul ist
sicher sagt der verteidigungsminister
wir werden die sicherheit der stadt mit
allen mitteln aufrechterhalten auch
präsident gar nicht bemühte sich in
einer kurzen ansprache die panik der
menschen vor dem zusammenbruch der
ordnung einzudämmen
ich habe armee und polizei angewiesen
für ruhe und sicherheit aller bürger zu
sorgen so gar nicht dem vernehmen nach
ist der präsident inzwischen auf dem weg
ins benachbarte tadschikistan
die terroristen haben ein klares ziel
afghanistan wieder zu einem islamischen
emirat machen scharia und
frauenunterdrückung inklusive in den
ländlichen stammesgebieten afghanistans
findet dass bei vielen männern
zustimmung und nicht nur dort
wir sind den krieg die bomben und die
anschläge leid das ändert sich
hoffentlich jetzt das islamische system
wird uns frieden und stabilität bringen
hoffe ich
sehr dass gewalt system der islamisten
ablehnt wird das anders sehen mut wohl
versuchen das land so schnell wie
möglich zu verlassen
an den kabel bin ich jetzt verbunden mit
stefan reker von der caritas wie erleben
sie denn die situation im moment fängt
ja erst nun also die situation ist
angespannt hier die menschen haben angst
wir hatten heute morgen international
mitarbeiterin mitarbeiter nach hause
geschickt als klar wurde dass die
taliban die taliban am golan angreifen
zuerst die frauen und dann später die
männer das hat ewig gedauert bis ich
nach hause kam wegen den verkehrsstaus
überall
die situation ist dahingehend auch jetzt
noch angespannt oder sogar noch mehr
angespannt weil wohl die polizei ihre
posten verlassen hat und jetzt kommt's
an patronen in die stadt rein um deren
deren aufgaben zu übernehmen und dann
müssen wir mal gucken die nacht wird
also ich hab da ein bisschen
befürchtungen vor plünderungen und wie
gesagt müssen wir gucken was passiert es
wird er unter hochdruck evakuiert was
wurde ihnen dann gesagt wer es
weitergeht
zwei stunden
erhalten dass ich auch realistisch die
auf die ich mich früher eingetragen
hatte diese fand liste dieser
elektronischen erfassung der
auslandsdeutschen
und dann musste ich mich wieder melden
bei einer emailadresse und jetzt wäre
ich wohl irgendwann evakuiert nur wann
demnach unter welchen bedingungen ist
unklar
die situation am flughafen ist auch
nicht gerade lustig weil sehr viele
menschen sind die auf irgendwelche
flieger versuchen zu kommen afghaninnen
und afghanen die richtige angst haben
von den taliban und das ist natürlich
eine sehr undurchsichtige situation
denn die menschen die nicht fliegen
können wenn die taliban die stadt jetzt
vollständig erobern
also bis jetzt haben die taliban
sich selbst so dargestellt als ob sie
keine gewalt anwenden möchten dass sie
keine rache aktion an der aktion in die
wege leiten werden gegen polizei gegen
regierungs mitarbeitende
da müssen auch gucken wie das wie das
nicht dass entwickeln wird bis jetzt
habe ich nur gutes gehört aus den
provinzen was die zusammenarbeit der
taliban mit dem hilfsorganisation
betrifft da gab es veränderungen von von
plünderungen
die wurden aktiv dahin bewegt weiter
hilfsprojekte durchzuführen also dass
das gab man nur gutes gehört bis jetzt
was passiert wenn die tage waren
komplett die macht im land übernommen
haben und sie kann er stört weiß man
aber die angst haben sie ja gesagt ist
doch schon groß
vielen dank
tja die sorge und die hoffnung der
hilfsorganisationen das gespräch haben
wir kurz vor der sendung aufgezeichnet
und sprechen jetzt nochmal mit katrin
eigendorf die für uns in den letzten
monaten immer wieder in afghanistan war
und die lage beobachtet inzwischen soll
auch der flughafen brennen was hören sie
denn über die neueste situation also es
zur stunde sehr schwierig sich ein bild
zu machen weil auch unsere mitarbeiter
eigentlich alle die die für westliche
medien arbeiten können nicht mehr
gefahrlos sich auf die straße trauen
können es ist wohl so dass massiv
militär am flughafen ist immer mehr
leute versuchen noch in letzter minute
auszureisen es scheint ziemlich
chaotische zustände dort zu herrschen
das ist meine letzte information was
relativ gesichert ist ist dass die
taliban dabei sind die macht in kabul zu
übernehmen es gibt zwar noch keine
offizielle regierungsübernahme aber
eigentlich ist klar eine
interimsregierung kann es nicht geben
das haben die taliban von anfang an
ausgeschlossen das ist das geben kann
sie wollen auch keine wahlen afghanistan
so stand heute abend wird künftig ein
islamisches emirat sein mit all den
konsequenzen also einen staat unter
scharia gesetze in denen sicherlich
frauenrechte keine gültigkeit mehr haben
in denen auch menschenrechte bedroht
sein werden und alle die die für ein
weltoffenes afghanistan eingetreten sind
müssen eigentlich jetzt um ihre
sicherheit fürchten
vielen dank für die einschätzung katrin
eigendorf
ja das war unser zdf spezial zur
dramatischen situation in afghanistan
mehr informationen jederzeit und der
zdf- heute- oder später dann im heute
journal
hier geht es jetzt weiter mit den zdf
sommerinterview mit christian lindner
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]